have you guys ever been to any of the
batting cages before yeah yeah i [ __ ]
love it a lot harder than it looks it is
a lot harder it's also a lot scarier
than it looks yeah because even when you
put it on like the slowest mode i think
a lot of machines throw at like 80
kilometers an hour and that's slow yeah
and you're like oh yeah that doesn't
sound too
fast or anything but then you remember
that's like the speed that cars travel
on some highways and you're like oh
that's
that's pretty fast i hit a car with a
baseball bat
[Music]
i can't hit a ball at one cost
my arms are probably fall off yeah yeah
yeah those those things are [ __ ] hard
i remember trying to do the 120 yeah out
of like 20 shots i managed to hit one
yeah that wasn't very good it was i was
just guessing it's getting used to the
speed it's got a lot harder learning
curve than when you play in every
[ __ ] mini game on like any any rpg
yeah because like in like you play on
like persona 5 whatever you missed the
first two shots persona yeah yeah yeah
yeah there's you can go to banning
yeah of course of course you can do
homework in persona why why couldn't you
like do like go to batting cages but
that's how you up your charisma dude
yeah
yeah
how does it up your charisma because the
more shots you get the more charismatic
you're so likable yeah it's like damn do
you got 19 out of 20 [ __ ]
just more charismatic as [ __ ] that weird
way to define that
yeah but i remember like you played on
persona or any minigame or [ __ ]
probably yakuza or something yeah of
course yeah i think you missed like the
first two balls and you're like okay i
got a feel for this yeah you started
getting them in real life you missed
like the first ten and you're like i
don't even i i can't even keep up with
this like my eyes still in real life
it's not even like you don't you can't
even attempt to swing after the first
view like the first few is like seeing
how fast the ball actually goes and by
the time you realize that it's behind
you like oh
okay i'm gonna be here for a while and
then maybe around like swing seven or
eight you're like i think i have the
courage to start swinging i just never
swing fast enough yeah my eyes were just
way faster than my arms yeah
that's what i learned
i mean i'm british so we don't play
baseball yeah no it's not a thing i mean
yeah i mean you know australia doesn't
play baseball why though so like holding
a baseball bat was just weird and trying
to hit a baseball yeah but we played
cricket
we i i didn't play cricket well the
welsh and the british i i did not play
any i've never played you play cricket i
played in the infield one time i had to
catch it but i never got to bat
but like everything we're on bats though
no but like because we were when we were
in school we only had like an hour right
so we didn't we never played it that
often right did you never play in like
pe or whatever i did but i i was always
in the infield i don't know why i don't
know why but like this team swap over
yeah i know but we never had time to run
out of time
sorry
we never played it often because you
know you have to do like every sport
yeah yeah so we didn't we only cricket
often i was never good at the team games
that's what i learned i'm really bad at
team games and we never did golf because
that's like how are you gonna get kids
to play golf yeah it's not i mean golf
wasn't like was never a pe thing it was
more of just like after yeah like a
extracurricular thing yeah yeah but we
did like
um i don't know we did like everything
what was your favorite sport during pu
i always liked athletics when we did
that like running long jump high jump
stuff like that yeah javelin jeffy fan
shot put was fun that's cause i was like
a [ __ ] animal you seemed like a short
form
you
i as much as i've tried my god damn
hardest i can't i cannot run long
distances right no matter how much i
practice i'm sure there's some god tier
runner in the comments being like you
just gotta you gotta power through man i
gotta hit that wall you gotta keep going
never stop get that pom-pom you gotta
breathe through your nose
you know like i
i am a sprinter that's what i always was
right and like whenever i
no matter how many times i trained i
just was [ __ ] doing long distance um but
i i wanted my to show goddamn bad
yeah so i ended up just doing sprinting
and like like cause i told you it's like
sprinting and like throwing and long
jump is all kind of explosive yeah yeah
yeah
for me yeah for me high jump and long
jump was like the ones i excelled
yeah long jump long jump for me was the
best one that i was that i was in
athletics as well i was just really good
at jumping i don't know
yeah yeah did you uh like my school's
really small yeah i've said this a bunch
so like i was the only one who went to
athletics after school like as we had
we had a local track that had been
founded by the lottery right so right
next to where i live there those amazing
facilities like amazing track nothing
like this anywhere else near me like
because this is just like unheard of it
was like an actual good track yeah so i
used to go there and i was the only
person in my like year who who did this
so i was the only one who knew how to
throw like a javelin need to throw a
shot putt knew how to do the long jump
like the correct way discus and stuff
like that i didn't do this so so um we
were doing it and uh every year we had
the sports day right you have to do to
track and field
and you had like houses yeah gryffindor
and [ __ ] yeah yeah like your own version
yeah yeah yeah i think i was in like
i was in like the house called scissors
this is scissors this is scissors there
wasn't rock or paper oh
so it was like sysodine or something
yeah and um
did you have how did you decide who does
the events how did you decide this uh
basically it was just like picked yeah
it was like would you like to go to this
there was someone who was obviously the
best at an event they would be like well
you're you're oh no for us it was just
like you just put your hand up it's like
who wants to do the 100 meter sprint and
then everyone who wants to puts their
hands up and then if you didn't want to
do it you didn't want so if there's too
many people how did they decide oh
everyone did it oh there's no limit yeah
well i mean to be fair my school as well
was also very very small like we only
had like you know 500 people in our
school how many people were in your
grade or year like
60. okay so yeah it's not same for me
yeah and so they there was like only
two or three people were allowed to do
each event right and
for the first few years when i did it
there was no limit on how many you could
do
and so i was just like i'll just i'll
just do like everything yeah because i
liked i loved sprinting i loved racing
as well yeah so i would be like yeah
i'll do the hundred 200 400 long jump
the triple jump javelin shot putt it was
fun it was good because there was some
people on uh my because we had like
groups of like 15 of us
and there was like half of them like i
don't wanna do anything yeah
you had like a maximum of four but like
everyone did like four or something
right see so then
there was one year where like i did the
100 200 and i'd won all of the events
but one and so i was like oh this is fun
i won like six out of seven events and
like and then the next year they were
like no
no you cannot do you want to watch you
can do three now and i was like
they just nerfed you i was like why are
you using me huh that's not fair but
this is this is the thing right is that
i'm sure if i went to any other school
where people like knew how to do like
throw a javelin correctly yeah or like
jump correctly because like this is when
like long jump everyone was still doing
the jump where you like just jump yeah
yeah not the one where you jump into a
sit yeah yeah yeah yeah so it was really
easy to like
do better yeah obviously yeah once
you've yeah i mean same with like uh
high jump as well right if you knew how
to get it yeah everyone just like did
like the you know the standing scissor
kick yeah way but like i was doing the
full like [ __ ] arch back like yeah
yeah yeah torpedo jump right and then
you're like oh my god this guy's a god
yes
the other kids can't compete if you're
like actually doing like professional
technique exactly i'm like oh yeah of
course you're only going to be able to
jump like a meeting you're [ __ ] doing
yeah of course i couldn't do that though
i was terrible i i i was really fun
though i i really liked it yeah i mean
when you're winning of course you like
it yeah yeah i thought that would make
me popular didn't they yeah yeah well
like during elementary i was like
dominating long jump in height
yeah
yeah guys yeah i'm here i definitely did
not make me popular if anything it just
gave the people more
right to be like oh your name's joey and
you're good at jumping things
just like a baby kangaroo i never
[ __ ] heard the end of that i
i'm christ
i just felt like i just saw your soul
just leave your eyes like like years of
like tournament just came rushing back